Judge Judy taught the new Forbes list of
the highest-paid TV host utter Oh Roz
judge Judy's income last year 147
million dollars according to Forbes that
figure is a combination of what she
makes most in Judge Judy and from
relinquishing the rights to past and
future show you left out a word stupid
Forbes estimates her network at four
hundred million dollars now et has been
with the feisty no-nonsense judge since
the beginning of her TV career when we
visited her home in Connecticut this is
such an adventure to travel first class
on an aeroplane for the first time is
really quite an exciting experience for
an old grandmother it could be next year
it's all over so next year I go to
Florida into the earlybird she's not
going anywhere for at least the next few
years judge judy has been renewed
through 2021 in October she told ET why
the show's format hasn't changed in 22
years we just do what has been
successful and what has been successful
is listening to information cutting
through the baloney telling a story once
upon a time the end next that's the
fourth year if it's not broken we're not
going to fix it
you